en train de faire bonjour et merci
d'être heures en direct avec nous sur rt
france alors voilà l'enquêté de nouveau
donc suspendu cette enquête sur
l'explosion du port de beyrouth quelle
est votre réaction aujourd'hui
effectivement c'est une question de deux
comptes publics s'ils voulaient ya le
tiers de la capitale libanaise qui sud
est détruit il ya c'est une c'est un
crime contre l'humanité jusqu'ici il ya
treize mois déjà la vérité n'est pas là
la justice n'est pas là il ya des
tractations politiques au niveau
judiciaire
et de points de vue procédural
actuellement le juge de bédard ne peut
plus procéder jusque jusqu'à la décision
finale de la cour d'appel soit prise 1 -
2 - il n'y a pas un délai c'est un délai
raisonnable suivant la la suivant la loi
car il n'y a pas un texte bien précis
qui précise le délai précis pour que la
cour d'appel
prenne une décision dans ce sens
à propos du dessaisissement du juge pas
mais actuellement nous sommes loin de la
justice jusqu'à nouvel ordre il faut
qu'il y ait une vérité une vérité fondée
sur des faits bien accompli pour que les
responsables disons les coupables soient
vraiment déférés devant la justice et
que la justice soit prise en
considération
pas pour les victimes seulement mais
pour l'avenir du liban pour la
crédibilité ou tout ce qui reste comme
crédibilité
pour le liban de par le monde
alors on sait que les temps étaient à
libanaises ont été souvent accusée de
négligence
pas la moindre enquête internationale
ils ont d'ailleurs rejeté cette requête
l'ouverture d'une enquête internationale
qu'elle est leur responsabilité dans ce
drame qui a qui a engendré voilà la
situation que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
vivant
en tant qu'avocat voyez j'ai pas je suis
pas en connaissance de cause des détails
de lanquais je peux pas dire qui est
responsable mais seulement il ya un ou
plusieurs responsables il y avait des
matières
toxiques des matières combustibles et
des matières qui sont prohibés
internationalement pour ted pas
entreposer dans une région comme le port
de belhout et ses alentours où il ya des
gens des résidences de tous alors ça
c'est de l'un d'eux seulement il ya des
responsables seulement il ya des
négligences seulement il ya des gentils
2 les plantes des
dépositions des allongements alors
seulement il ya quelque chose qui ne va
pas dans ce sens au niveau
des responsables politiques peut-être
judiciaire peut être militaire c'est pas
à nous de deux procédés et de dire qui
sont les responsables
celle enquête qui doit répondre à toutes
ces questions d'une façon ferme crédible
concise et précise afin de crédibiliser
le système judiciaire qui est en
désarroi actuellement à cause de la
mainmise politique à cause de tout ce
qui se passe de point de vue corruption
politique constitutionnelle juridique
tour au liban actuellement tout est
considérée contre un point de vue même
la justice même la loi même les
allongements même les procédures même
tout ça c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'étrange c'est quelque chose qui incite
les gens surtout les jeunes libanais a
quitté le pays et pour de bon c'est pour
cela il ya le troisième épisode après la
première guerre mondiale après la guerre
civile qui a eu lieu au liban et puis
actuellement nous sommes devant le
troisième épisode ça c'est grave ce qui
se passe au liban
c'est pour cela on attend une certaine
vérité il ya des gens qui ont perdu le
fils leurs enfants leur père leur
domicile et leur travail et qui boira
cette exigence ces gens doivent
connaître la vérité la vérité au service
de la justice pas au service politique
ils ont politisé ce ce phénomène ce
crime
l'ampleur est plutôt politique que
judiciaire c'est pour cela on doit
réajuster tout ça dans le sens de servir
la justice de nouveau espérons la
dernière question pourquoi jusqu'à
aujourd'hui le parlement refuse de lever
justement l'immunité de certains députés
concernant cette enquête
ici une question de compétences
actuellement dans un système semi
parlementaire comme le nôtre il ya une
immunité donné si vous voulez aux
parlementaires mais c'est un concept de
garantie c'est pas un concept de
protection c'est pour cela on doit
l'utiliser à mon sens c'est à dire une
garantie pour le parlementaire en sa
qualité de plaisantes hâtive pas en sa
qualité de personne qu'il peut commettre
des crimes qui peut commettre des fautes
qui peut commettre quoi que ce soit
alors ça c'est d'homme avec le haut
conseil pour le jugement des présidents
et des ministres qui n'a jamais
fonctionné qui ne fonctionnera jamais à
cause des dissensions politiques et de
la diversité du parlement libanais et de
la constitution du parlement libanais
politiquement confessionnellement alors
ils ont voulu créer une certaine
immunité au ministre le ministre et le
premier ministre n'ont pas d'immunité
dans un régime parlementaire ils peuvent
être ils doivent être déférés pour les
juger devant les télés de nordine est
surtout que ce crime a été transféré par
le conseil des ministres devant la cour
date
de justice et la justice doit doit
procéder dans ce sens sans considération
quelconque c'est l'immunité et la poule
protéger c'est c'est pas clair c'est pas
bon c'est pas juste du tout il faut
plaindre dit militer dans le texte
suivant le texte dans textuellement et
dans son esprit
merci beaucoup antoine sfeir d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat et maître de
conférences à l'université saint-joseph
aberrante